bonjour phrase à meillon bonjour vous
êtes vice président de l'association des
agences en conseil communication hier
technopole martinique la pépinière
d'entreprises de la cacem organisé une
rencontre autour du sponsoring du
mécénat des partenariats pour les
petites entreprises qui démarrent avec
une question frank d'amelio quels choix
pour ces entreprises
parce que dès que l'on démarre on se
pose déjà ce genre de questions dès
qu'on se pose la question en fait de
faire connaître son entreprise et on
essaie de trouver également je dirais
des sources de financement et quelque
part il ya parfois un peu mélange dans
la tête des des chefs d'entreprises
surtout des créateurs d'entreprise en
disant pourquoi est-ce que le sponsor et
le mécénat ou des partenariats ne
pourrait pas être faire partie en tout
cas de la panoplie de communication ou
de financement des entreprises dans dès
le départ il faut y penser
oui parce que dans la réalité la chose
la plus importante pour une entreprise
c'est sa marque
c'est peut-être un peu dur ce que je
vais dire mais plus important que le
produit plus important que les locaux
plus important peut parfois même que le
personnel
c'est la marque est la chose la plus
importante parce que finalement le
client ce qu'ils achètent c'est ça il
faut se faire parler de soi il faut
faire parler de soi c'est un portrait
qu'importe la manière
non je dirais pas ça il faudra que des
tic dans la communication autrement ray
publicité sans conscience n'est que
ruine son image le rôle si troillet sa
fiscalité ce sont des arguments qui
doivent également rentrer dans la tête
de l'entrepreneur très tôt parce que
on va être dépendant en fait d'un
certain nombre de règles de loi de
législation et quand on est chef
d'entreprise en tout cas quand on fait
le choix de l'être parce que c'est un
véritable choix on doit être un homme
orchestre et avoir une
formation généraliste en tout cas de ce
point de vue là les techniciens sont
parfois excellents dans leur technique
et ils ne font pas forcément de bons
chefs d'entreprise alors on doit quand
même avant de poursuivre frank d'amelio
rappeler quelques petits trucs c'est
quoi la différence entre le sponsoring
mécénat et le partenariat
on va essayer d'être rapide parce
qu'autrement enfin les venir à la
maintenant le le sponsor est en fait une
entreprise rentrer dans une opération de
sponsoring et en attend un retour d'un
certain âge à marcq
voilà exactement souvent ces opérations
sont liées à des opérations culturelles
sportives etc dans le mécénat en fait
l'entreprise n'entend absolument rien en
terme de retour
maintenant quand on dit rien du tout ça
peut malgré tout être en interne et ça
peut être également d'un point de vue
fiscal parce que quand on est dans une
opération de mécénat en fait on
défiscalise entre guillemets une partie
de de serre hausse de ses revenus qui
vont aider une cause une association est
souvent c'est une mise en avant des
valeurs de l'entreprise à l'intérieur du
mécénat et le partenariat
c'est le couteau suisse et en 8 ou voir
des filières où ce qu'on dit mais on va
y trouver du coc brandi on va y trouver
des relations avec des distributeurs
pour distribuer ensemble sont produits
je sais pas moi si vous vendez du café
et du sud vous pouvez mettre les deux
éducatrices qui nous en font aujourd'hui
un petit peu difficile
alors ça petit alors de l'autre côté de
la barrière il ya ccc associations par
exemple qui pour qu'ils attendent qu'ils
attendent de ce partenariat avec les
marques
que ce soit sous forme de messina ou de
sponsoring ces associations est ce qu
elles jouent le jeu et ce qu'elles
savent aller vers des entreprises
est ce qu'elles savent les dénicher
surtout en fait est ce qu'on peut
demander dans un premier temps oui vous
êtes tout à fait raison
les associations se disent il faut qu'on
trouve des sources de financement
complémentaire ou même premières et les
entreprises sont tout naturellement je
dirais des partenaires dans ce cadre là
parce que c'est l'endroit où on produit
de la richesse women et des entreprises
souvent de plus en plus dix ne sommes
pas des vaches à lait de système qui ne
fonctionne plus c'est une réalité parce
que si je suis une entreprise et que je
sponsorise une opération ou en clubs
sportifs pour prendre cet exemple là et
bien j'en attend en retour
ce retour il il est relativement bien
codifié parce que premièrement
fiscalement c'est pas du tout évident de
dire ok je vais donner dix mille euros à
une association et après le fisc va me
dire oui mais attendez
cet argent vous l'avez donné pourquoi
quelle était la raison vous avez
détourné des fonds vous avez donné de
l'argent à quelqu'un que vous aimez bien
mais c'est pas ça l'objectif une
entreprise c'est une personne morale
on doit d'abord utilisé l'argent à bon
escient et souvent en fait les
associations ne comprennent pas en fait
ce sujet là ils se disent c'est un chef
d'entreprise il fait ce qu'il veut de
son argent c'est pas si vrai que ça
autre question lorsque l'entreprise
réfléchi autour du sponsoring du mécénat
et qu'elle a une association par exemple
de quartier qui de football basket
n'importe quoi d'autre cette entreprise
est en droit d'attendre que cette
association fonctionne relativement bien
avec des codes bien établis
bref que ce soit professionnel quoi oui
c'est c'est peut-être tout le paradoxe
de la chose c'est que d'un côté on a des
bénévoles donc ils sont pas des
professionnels a priori qui donnent de
leur temps ce qui est déjà beaucoup de
français la rieuse de leur activité en
plus voilà c'est ça mais qui vont se
retrouver confrontés en fait à des
entreprises qui donnent de l'argent et
qui vous dira oui mais bon moi ce que je
veux c'est que ma marque soit présente
comme ça je veux que ma banderole m'ont
enfin mes supports de communication
soient mises en avant
je veux qu'il soit ensuite bien rangée
stocker que vous voulez rendiez et je
veux dire c'est un vrai travail de titan
en réalité pour des
dirigeants d'associations qui n'ont pas
que ça à faire qui vous le rappeliez
également d'autres propositions ce sont
des bénévoles sont pas rémunérés pour ça
donc et de tous et qui font surtout
cette activité bénévole en décalage par
rapport aux horaires par exemple
d'ouverture de tel ou tel organisme que
c'est très difficile à mettre ça en
branle
et lorsqu'on entend parler de
professionnalisation c'est une très
difficile alors quelle serait
l'alternative
bah moi je crois que la problématique
c'est de trouver des solutions de moyens
pour pouvoir répondre en fait à la
problématique de professionnalisation de
la gestion
on va dire des associations alors pour
moi ce qu'il en est j'en parle surtout
de la partie de communication mais
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut imaginer
un journal papier sans publicité ou même
sur le web
on voit bien qu'en fait la communication
publicitaire a besoin d'espacé
d'exposition et en contrepartie elle va
donner des moyens
ces moyens doivent servir aux
associations pour se structurer
comment le faire je pense que la
mutualisation entre associations
sportives et peut-être même au-delà
parle mais c'est très difficile pour ces
associations parce que il faut pouvoir
avoir le temps de se rencontrer entre
plusieurs associations qui ont force qui
n'ont pas forcément les hommes les mêmes
objets c'est difficile de te mettre tout
cela en commun
oui je crois qu'il ya malgré tout des
organismes qui sont comme le cosma etc
qui pourraient le faire enfin je vais
pas vous cacher qu'il ya quelques années
nous avions nous au sein de notre agence
cible des agences de communication mis
en avant une structure qui s'appelait et
sport et dans l'objectif c'était cela ça
n'a pas abouti parce que bien des
difficultés je dirais de compréhension
des objectifs peut-être qu'on s'était
mal expliqué aussi mais en tout état de
cause en fait on a réussi à rassembler
un certain nombre d'associations mais
qui au dernier moment en fait on fait
machine arrière
voilà alors aujourd'hui puisque la
question on le rappelle pour les
entreprises qui se lancent quel choix
faire
entre le sponsoring entre le sénat entre
le partenariat
forcément il faudra casser le cercle que
nous connaissons actuellement qui doit
prendre l'initiative
comment ça doit se passer je pense que
très sincèrement plutôt que ce sont les
politiques qui doivent prendre là cette
décision qui doivent permettre de casser
ou d'assembler un cercle vertueux
il faut qu'il ya un point de départ ce
point de départ ces lois permettent en
fait l'association si mal en fait ces
politiques qui sont dues par exemple à
disposition des associations des
contrats aidés fonctionne mais voilà
toutes les associations dommage parce
que c'est pas bien s'achève je pense que
c'est l'objectif qui pose problème
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est d'une
association dans une danse dans un
quartier dans une commune parce qu'elle
n'a pas de recette n'a pas de
billetterie parce qu'elle n'a pas
d'argent qui rentre pour pouvoir faire
mettre des personnes à disposition pour
accueillir 200 gamins de mercredi après
midi
voilà mais je pense que justement c'est
passé à l'objectif je pense qu'il faut
remettre à plat la problématique les
moyens des associations doivent être
pérennisés
c'est pas avec des contrats aidés qu'on
va pérenniser les moyens parce que par
définition ce sont des contrats qui sont
qui vont se terminer un jour comment
est-ce qu'une association peut imaginer
pérenniser en fait ça sa structure son
fonctionnement avec des des moyens qui
compte par définition on parle de
subventions qui par définition en fait
peuvent disparaître tous les cinq ans ça
ça peut pas marcher et on peut pas
demander à un comité directeur un
président l'association de s'engager au
delà de ça en plus de ça chaque année
lui-même peut se retrouver sur la
sellette disparaissent les entreprises
ont besoin pérennité et cette
pérennisation pour pouvoir faire
confiance à une association lui donnant
de l'argent sur plusieurs années avec
des contrats qui peuvent durer 5 ans 10
ans je sais pas eh bien ça passe
nécessairement par une
professionnalisation du secteur
on peut tourner le sujet dans tous les
sens et il ya plein de problèmes je vais
pas toutes les solutions
seulement je dis que si aujourd'hui les
politiques pouvaient nous donner en fait
les moyens de déclencher un système
ensuite les associations pour s
assembler en mutualisation est confiant
en fait leur travail à des
professionnels parce que c'est ça la
solution
merci d'arrêter ce matin avec nos
propres amis on aurait pu continuer
longtemps sur ce thème qui très porteur
celui des associations du sponsoring du
mécénat et de partenariat avec elle les
associations merci bonne journée
merci on va prendre une tasse de café
[Musique]